so we've been talking about
p and np
and the time complexity classes
and today we're going to shift gear
we're going to talk about uh space
complexity or memory complexity as uh
space complexity is what complexity
theorists uh usually refer
refer to it as
um
and um
you know time and space are the two
basic most basic measures of complexity
that uh that we consider and so um today
we're going to look at the the second of
those two um the space complexity
uh so we will
define
a lot of this is going to be
by analogy with what
we did for time complexity we're going
to define complexity classes we'll talk
about
polynomial space and non-deterministic
polynomial space
um see how those
classes connect up with the time
complexity classes that we've already
defined
and we'll do some examples that will be
setting us up for our
further discussion about space
complexity next week
so
we're going to talk about first of all
what it means for a turing machine
to run in a certain
certain amount of space
and that's simply going to be counting
the number of cells that the turing
machine
scans over
on its tape during the course of its
computation you might be reading that
cell might be writing on that cell but
the total number of cells that it
actually um
visits
um of course visiting the same cell
multiple times only counts once because
space can be reused
but we're going to count the number of
cells that the turing machine visits
during the course of its computation and
then define
the space utilization by analogy with
what we did for time so we'll say a
turing machine runs in a certain amount
of space f n we'll say
if first of all it has to always hold so
all of the machines are deciders
and it uses at most
that much uh tape that much that
it visits that number of cells
on all
inputs of length n
so just like we said for time complexity
the machine has to run within
t of n time
on all inputs
of length n here it's going to have to
use at most f of n
cells
on all inputs of length n in order for
it to be running in space f n
okay a tape cell is simply a little
square of the tape where you can write a
symbol
okay answering a question that good
question that came in from the chat
so um you know
uh
i'm not sure we have i have a
diagram for that but the um in each of
the little squares on the tape are going
to be the tape cells
generally we're going to be sticking to
one tape turing machines but i'll make a
brief remark about multi-tape during
machining shortly
better take cells
sorry
uh on all inputs of length n
uh so return
now okay so that's for deterministic uh
turing machines
for non-deterministic touring machines
we will say uh that it
also runs in a certain amount of space
so for a
non-deterministic machine
it has to
use
at most
that many tape cells
on each branch of its computation
separately you don't add up the total
number of cells used across all of the
branches just like we don't add up the
total amount of time the machine
uses across all of its branches for the
machine to be running in say space n
squared
it has to be using it most n squared
cells
or order n squared cells on each one of
its non-deterministic branches
separately
there might be exponentially many
branches but that's okay
but on each branch it's going to be
using at most n squared or order n
squared cells
importantly though that still the
machine has to be a decider
it's not enough to be looping forever
and using a small amount of space
it could do that but that's not going to
count toward the machine contributing to
its um
space complexity of that language so for
the machine to be running in a certain
amount of space we say that the machine
holds on all of its branches
and each one of its branches uses at
most
that much space okay
again
i can see lots of typos here thank you
um
i messed this all up today
uh
some non-deterministic
good thank you
um
all right so we're going to define the
space complexity classes analogous to
this time complexity classes so these
are languages
that you can do
with machines
that run within that space bound
so
um space f n you can think of space n
squared
um is all of the languages
that a deterministic one tape turing
machine
um can do
within uh can decide within by using in
most n-squared tape cells or order
n-squared tape cells similarly the
non-deterministic space
complexity class are all of the
languages that are non-deterministic one
tape turing machine can decide
running within that amount of space
okay
and lastly
we have a polynomial space
so that's the union over all polynomial
space bounds of the space complexity
class and non-deterministic polynomial
space
it's the same for all of the
non-deterministic
uh polynomial space classes
okay
so i think i do have a check-in on this
um
whoops
which talks about
uh multi-tape turing machines
so we could define
space complexity for multi-tape turing
machines just as we've been doing which
is we did for one tape turning machines
and then define the associated space
complexity classes and then define
the class p space but that would be for
multi-turing machines
now for time
uh
remember that the class p
that you would get from multitape turing
machines is exactly the same as the
class p that we got for one tape turing
machines um that was part of the
nice
quality of the class p it's robust in
that sense a natural so how about for p
space um what do you think do we get the
same class
um
no maybe
or
yes because we can convert a multi-tape
turning machine to a single tape turning
machine by only squaring the amount of
space
um
that was what happened with time as you
remember
or maybe we can do even better
converting a multi-tape touring machine
to single tape only increases it by by
less by say a constant factor here
remember how this is how we're defining
space complexity for multi-tape turing
machines we're taking the sum of all the
cells used on all of the tapes
all right so
let's launch that poll and see what you
think
hopefully this is not
too
hard um
yeah i think most of you have got the
idea though some of you are
i worry sometimes about some of the
answers that i get
i don't know if you're serious or
you're really com
badly confused
but anyway let's
let's wrap this up another
10 seconds or so
let's call
okay i'm gonna end it
yeah i mean i
uh i think
answer b is a reasonable answer in fact
uh answer c is the correct answer uh you
can if you just look at the same
simulation from multi-tape to single
tape
and how much space overhead that
simulation introduces
um it's only linear you're basically
just taking all of the tapes of the
multitape machine and writing them down
next to one another
obviously you know ignoring all the
infinite infinitely many blanks we're
just taking the active portion of the
tapes writing them down next to each
other so the total amount used is just
going to be the sum
on the single tape of what was used on
each of the
individual multitapes in the original
machine
so there's just a linear cost overhead
by converting from multi-tape to single
tape when you're looking at space the
amount of memory that's used
for time remember there was some
additional overhead because we had to be
uh updating um where the virtual heads
were and that uh cost extra time to move
our single head around to do that but
for space
the amount of time that's introduced is
not as irrelevant we're only looking at
the amount of memory and so that's a um
link going to just uh you know
the overhead on that is very low
i would do worry about the folks who are
answering a for example in this uh for
this question you should be
rethinking
what's what what's really going on here
um
uh so
okay
um
now
let us
um
move on here from from that to our next
uh slide
and
compare
uh the time and space complexity classes
you know or time and space complexity
how do they relate to one another
and so first of all we're going to point
out
um
let's
uh start out
here
t of n is going to be represent some
bound either on the time or the amount
of space and generally at least up till
this point um and most of the mostly
going forward though there's going to be
one
variation on that a little later but
we're going to be focusing on
uh bounds which are at least
big enough to either read the input or
at least hold the input that's why we
we refer to t of n being at least n
um
so now if we
look at
uh the time complexity class t of n
think of that t of n like typically
would be say n squared maybe
and the things that you can do
in n squared time
i claim you can also do in n squared
space
um
and basically
um it's just using the very same machine
suppose you have a machine that runs in
n squared time how could it possibly use
say n square n cubed space if it's
running only in n square time
even if it tries to use as much state as
it possibly could as many tape cells as
it possibly could
and you know sending its head cruising
out um into the blind portion of the
tape chewing up as much uh as many tape
cells as it possibly can in in n squared
time it's only going to be able to use n
squared space so the very same machine
that runs in t of n time is also going
to run in t event space um so this
containment here
follows you know really without doing um
any work at all um
so just re restating that here um a
uh turing machine that runs in t of n
steps cannot use more than t of n tape
cells
okay so right now we're focusing on we
could prove some analogous statements
about
non-deterministic complexity um but
let's focus here on the deterministic
complexity
now let's look at going the other
direction suppose we have a turing
machine
that uses t of n
space now
does that immediately imply it's using
only t of n and time
and that's
uh not so clear and in fact probably not
true
because
a space appears to be much more powerful
than time and within a certain amount of
space you can run for much longer than
that same amount of time um so how long
could you run
so what which you can
show is that if you're running uh within
a certain amount of space t event space
let's say
n squared space for example
the amount of time you could use is
going to be exponential in n squared a 2
to the order n squared
sometimes we also write that as
the union of
c to the um n squared by sort of pulling
down that constant here if you want well
it's also just to understand what we
mean by order t of n up in the exponent
it means that
the union over c to the t of n for all c
either of these are just completely
equivalent so whichever one you're more
comfortable with
but why is this going to be true why
does a turing machine that runs in say
um
uh
say n squared space
use
at most
uh
two to the order n squared time
and that's because if you look at how
many possible configurations the machine
can have
remember that a configuration is is
essentially
the contents of the tape this is also
the head position and the state but the
dominant um
uh
the dominant aspect of a configuration
is the tape and so how many different
tape contents can you have
well it's going to be exponential in the
saw in the length of that tape
because you know each cell can have some
fixed number of symbols in it
if a machine
repeats a configuration it's going to go
forever which we're forbidding um in uh
you know in the in these machines
because they're all going to be deciders
so they can only run
um
uh for an amount of time which is
bounded by the number of configurations
that the machine can have
and so the machine can have
you know if it's running in t of n space
then the amount of
time that it could be running is going
to be at most some constant to the t of
n
or two to the order of t events saying
the same thing
uh uh you know unless it's going to
repeat a configuration and end up
looping
okay so these are the two fundamental
connections between time and space
time is contained within the same amount
of space space is contained within that
amount of time exponentiated
okay um so one car reliary of that is
that the class p is contained within p
space
similarly np is going to be contained
within an np space for the very same
reason
um
okay is this
understandable
you know this is this is a good place or
in a moment to have one more line to
to to to tell you about but leading into
the next slide so
if you understand the definitions
of what we've done so far
all of the the the this is a this is a
fairly straightforward theorem and the
and the corollary is immediate
okay so
um
anything that you can do in n squared
time you can do an n squared space and
so for if anything you can do in
polynomial time you can also do in
polynomial space
yes c somebody's asking me you know what
is the c c is essentially going to be
the size of the tape alphabet
um
because that's going to govern how many
different configurations you have
there's a slight extra uh factor it's
like you know slight extra factor for
the tape um
the the head location and also the
um state but uh the the main thing is
going to be the
number of tape symbols and the length of
the tape
okay but what's going to come next is
we're going to prove something more
powerful than
this corollary that p is contained in p
space because not only is p contained in
p space but np is also contained in p
space and for that we're going to have
to do more work
so somebody's asking me about the number
of states the number of states
is going to be indep is fixed depend
upon depending on the machine only
so um
they it doesn't depend upon the
uh depend up on n so it could in most
affect
the
number configurations by a constant
factor
and those constant factors are going to
be absorbed
within the definitions of these uh
complexity classes because that's how we
would define them to be um
uh
you know
ignoring the constant factors
but you know
why don't we just take a
you know this may be a good place to
pause for a second and see if there's
any questions
because you know
i think for some of you this may be um
straightforward but you know i i think
it's less common to be measuring
thinking about uh
the amount of memory as a complexity
measure um so this is perhaps a little
less familiar some of you have seen
measuring time and other classes but
remember
measuring the the amount of space that
the algorithm uses probably is a little
less familiar and maybe that's it's
worth spending a moment or two answering
questions about that
so i'm not sure i understand the
question that just came in but i'll i'll
read it out there is it possible that a
turing machine can loop forever
absolutely but a turing machine that
loops forever does not count as one that
runs within the space bound to run
within the space bound the machine must
halt on every input it has to be a
decider we're only considering deciders
here
so is it possible that turn machine can
look forever yes isn't the turing
machine we're talking about a member of
space and thus a decider
um
not totally sure i understand the
question but
if a
turing machine is
not
halting on all inputs it's not a decider
that's our definition
um
are we good and we're not getting very
many questions here so i'm assuming
you're all with me
or
so lost you don't even know what to ask
which is not good
um so be bold if you're confused throw
our question out there because i'm i i
don't want to race through this lecture
since it's it's maybe a little less
familiar to some of you
okay so let's move on
um
as promised i'm going to show you now
that np
not only p as is kind of happens
immediately but np
is contained as a subset of a p space
so that is oh
i didn't get a question i
moved on before i answered this question
can i explain part two of the proof
again part two okay let's just do it um
uh
if something runs in a certain amount of
space you have to just think about how
many different configurations the
machine can have within that amount of
space remember the configurations that
we defined way back at lbas
um
so the number of configurations the
machine can have depends on how much
space it's allocated
like the lbas they had a fixed number of
configurations and we gave a calculation
for that
um
which is basically an exponential in the
amount of space that's how many
configurations the machine can have
so
if the machine is not a is not looping
if it's a decider it can never repeat a
configuration and that's going to tell
us how long the machine can possibly run
for
you know it's a
it's it's it's important to understand
i'm not sure if i knew how to say that
in any way be that different from what i
said before but um
okay getting back now
to proving that np is a subset of p
space so now we're going to have to do
something that's sort of in a way uh
different from what we did on the
previous slide because now
it's not going to be enough to work with
the same machine before when we were
converting we're showing that a certain
amount of time time classes contained
within a spaceclass it was by virtue of
the very same machine by just showing
that if it's running within a certain
amount of time then it has to be running
within that same amount of sp within
that same amount of space um
or in terms of the space it was in the x
given a certain amount of space it has
to be running that same machine within a
certain amount of time
here we're going to mixing
non-determinism and determinism so we're
going to have to take a machine that's
in uh an np type machine a
non-deterministic polynomial time
machine
and convert it into a deterministic
machine that doesn't use a whole lot of
space
so there's
a difference in the
character of this theorem because we
have to introduce a new machine
um
and the way we're going to prove that um
i i'm going to take advantage of some of
the things we've already shown
to prove this one could also prove it a
little bit more directly and maybe it's
worth understanding making sure you
understand both proofs
so the first thing i'm going to observe
is that sat
our np complete language
um the satisfiability language
itself is a member of p space
and the reason for that is
um when you're given
a formula
and now you want to test if that formula
is satisfiable
one way to do it
the most obvious way to do it is try all
assignments
one by one
and see if any of them satisfy the
formula
now that's going to take a lot of time
but how much space does it use
i have in mind reusing the space every
time we try the next assignment
think of going through all of the
assignments the way an odometer would
work
just trying every possible assignment
but reusing the space where you're going
to write that assignment down
um
sort of incrementing it like like a
number um written in binary if you wish
um
going through all the possible
assignments every time you get in the
next assignment you plug it into the
formula and see if the formula is
satisfied if it is then you can accept
immediately if not you go on to the next
assignment and only when you've gone
through all the assignments in that way
and none of them have satisfied the
formula then you can reject so how much
space does that use
that doesn't use a whole lot of space
because you're reusing the space
um to write down one assignment after
the next okay it's only going to be
using an amount of space which is big
enough to hold an assignment which is
basically linear because it's the size
of the number of variables of the
formula so
that's going to be a linear amount of
space to solve the satisfiability
problem and so the satisfiability
problem is certainly in p space
um
step one
step two
is we're going to take advantage
of what we know about reducibility
um so if a is polynomial time reducible
to b
we've already commented we didn't say
this exactly in this way but you know
it's still going to follow that anything
you can do in a certain amount of time
you can also do in that amount of space
because there's a very same machine um
doesn't can't use any more space than
the amount of time it was allocated
so if a is polynomial time reducible to
b
it's also going to be reducible in
polynomial space the a polynomial space
machine could do the reduction
so that means if a
is polynomial time reducible to b and b
is in polynomial space then a is also in
polynomial space
but we know
because satisfiability is np-complete
that every language of np
is reducible to sat so put sat in place
of b every np language is polynomial
time reducible to sat
and we now know that sat is in p space
so therefore every language in np is in
p space because they're all polynomial
time reducible to set
okay so just by using some of the
technology we've developed
namely the notion of completeness sort
of shows us some of its power that if
you want to
conclude something about an entire class
an entire complexity class if you have a
complete problem for that complexity
class often it's enough just to work
with the complete problem and then
everything else by virtue of the
reducibility is going to
inherit the same property it doesn't
work in all cases but in many of the
cases as long as the um you know the
reducibility can be computed by the um
by the
the type of procedure you're working
with um then you can then it follows
uh you know you could also prove this
more directly i think it's in some ways
a little clumsy or a little bit um
less elegant but you can say well let me
just take my
um
uh take a language that's in np it has a
non-deterministic polynomial time
algorithm
and then give a deterministic polynomial
space algorithm simulates that
np algorithm just by going through all
the different branches but making sure
that going through all those different
branches you're reusing the space and
not using new space every time you're
going through a different branch and you
can arrange things if you're just a
little bit careful to do it that way so
you could give a direct simulation in
polynomial space of any
uh np turing machine so that i mean
that's also completely satisfactory but
i think this is a little more elegant
so now let's also this
furthermore is going to allow us to
conclude some additional
languages are in p space
let's define a class we have not yet
seen though maybe you've seen this i
think we've talked about this this
notion of uh
co
before um i think we talked about
co-touring reducib
co touring recognizable um so
uh
the class
those are the class of languages whose
complements are turning recognizable and
the same for co and p
this is the class of languages whose
complements are in np
so you take the complement of every
language that's in np and now you get
all the languages that are in this class
co np
complement of np
um
so for example the complement of the
hand handpath problem so all the graphs
which don't have
hamiltonian paths from uh you know
esthetic so the the the non-hamiltonian
uh graph uh the non-hamiltonian path
problem
that's a cohen p problem
um well here's a language we haven't
i'm not going to define
uh as in terms of its complement it's a
the tautology problem so these are the
problem language
these are all formulas or these are the
formulas where all assignments satisfy
the formula all assignments make the
formula true
um so a tautology is a statement that's
always true
so
no matter how you plug in the variables
the the tautology tautology language is
in co-np
um because it's complement which is the
non-tautologies those are the
formulas for which
um there's some assignment which makes
it false so that's going to be clearly
an np language
so tautology is a co and p language
okay
um
now one thing that we
get immediately from the theorem as a
corollary really should write this as a
corollary is that cohen p
is also a subset of p space
and the reason for that is and this is
something that
you know it's um
again
easy but make sure you understand it
is that
p space itself is closed under
complement
because it is
defined in terms of deterministic
machines and deterministic machines you
can always flip the answer
and get a machine
of the same type
which um
uh
uh will decide the complementary
language
so for deterministic machines
deterministic deciders i should say um
you can always flip the answer
um
now
so here we have anything that's in p
space
it has a deterministic polynomial time a
polynomial space uh machine and so its
complementary line which is also going
to be in p space so p space and cos base
p co p space are equal and so that's why
coen p
uh is going to be in p space it's going
to be a subset of p space
okay i hope that's
not getting mixed up by all of the
different uh
alphabet soup here but um
uh
here is maybe a picture maybe that'll be
helpful uh of how the world looks for
the time and spice uh complexity classes
um so far
uh so
we have p
is a subset of np it's also a subset of
co np
um
again for the same reason that p and co
p are equal we never never even really
talk about copy because it's the same as
p
um
uh but np and cohen p
that those are two classes where we
don't know whether they're equal or not
uh because an np machine
um
you know you can't necessarily
complement the
behavior of an np machine and end up
with an np machine
so a question how do we know that cohen
p is a complete class of problems i
didn't say that there's anything about
completeness and cohen p is just a
collection of languages i'm not saying
it's anything any particular feature
about it in fact it does have a complete
problem just like np has a complete
complete problem the complements
and i'm not going to prove this right
here but though it's pretty
straightforward
complements of all the np-complete
languages are going to be co-np-complete
languages
um
and um
so
uh
so i'm getting so okay so let's
i will answer some of the questions
about or about
possible alternate worlds this is how we
believe the world looks like
with each one of these regions being
separated from one another including
this little
corner of the world here np and
intersect co-np which is not um there
might be languages in here which are not
in p and we actually believe there are
such languages but again all of this is
conjectural um and even whether p and p
space are the same or different is an un
is an open question
we don't even know the answer to that
which is perhaps even more shocking that
we don't know how to solve pnn
you know proved p different from np that
we don't know how to prove p different
from p space which seems to be a much
bigger class
uh it would be incredible that anything
you can do with a polynomial amount of
space
uh you can also do with a polynomial
amount of time
um but
i don't know how to prove that they're
different and in fact so this is how the
world could look
um
everything could collapse down p could
equal p space
and then all of these classes would be
the same
um
and i should also mention i don't have
this as another diagram here but just to
answer
you know there's also another pos
there's other possibilities for example
um
p could equal np
without it being equal to p space
and then you'd have a different looking
venn diagram here where there'd be just
two classes p np and co np would all be
the same p space would be different
that's possible
at least we have no idea
uh had a head of m
a a lot of these things can collapse in
in various ways
um and you just have to make sure that
you you know there are some collapses
that obviously could not uh occur like p
if p equals np it's also going to equal
cohen p
um so you can't get some there are
obviously some crazy collapses which
could not
uh happen that p collapsing p and np
being the same but different from cohen
b that can't happen
but um
avoiding some obvious contradictory
situations everything else is possible
so somebody said so well here's a
question let me just answer a few of
these
did we use the completeness of co np to
show that cohen p is
a subset of co-p space no we didn't do
it that way
we showed that uh co-np
um
uh
well let's see didn't we is that fair um
well i i suppose you know np of subset
of p space immediately implies because
he's complementing both sides that cohen
p is a subset of copy space
so you don't have to deal with
the complete problems on the other side
that's too complicated to get into here
but you don't you don't need to talk
about
co-empty complete problems um though
again those are very simple to to get
from np complete problems
um
let's see what else is here
uh
are there np complete problems that are
in co-np
so the answer to that is no
not as far as well i mean there would be
if there was an np complete problem in
co-np then all of np would be in cohen p
and they would be equal
so we suspect the np complete problems
are not in co and p but don't know how
to prove that
so why is tautology
in cohen p so here is tautology sits in
this class here the reason is that its
complementary language is an np the
complement of tautology
are the languages where there is some
assignment
which makes the formula false
so with a with an np machine you can
just guess that assignment and check
that it makes the formula false
so the complement of tautology
is an np language and so tautology is a
co-np language
um
okay uh
so somebody's asking about p space and
np-space and how do those relate to one
another so that's looking ahead um to
what we're going to be doing next week
but i'll give you a preview
an old but at the time surprising
theorem was that
piece base and np space actually are
equal
so there this analogy with time breaks
down
so polynomial space and
non-deterministic polynomial space do
turn out to be equal
the most obvious way of proving of
trying to simulate an np an np space
machine would be give you an exponential
deterministic space algorithm uh so
we'll go through that but there is an
algorithm which
collapses
non-deterministic polynomial space down
to deterministic polynomial space which
again at the time was kind of surprising
uh
and so last question i'll take here is
there some equivalent concept to the
idea of a certificate for co-np
yes there is a notion of a certificate
but now it's going to be a certificate
that you're not in the language instead
of a certificate that you're in the
language
and then again works for the very same
reason that we had certificates for np
languages where you had certificate for
membership for cohenp you have a
certificate for non-membership i don't
know if there's no other certificate for
membership in co mp
um okay so let's move on
um
okay so now we're going to introduce
we're going to look at some important
examples these are examples that we're
going to um i'm going to give you two
examples first one called tqbf
and then we're going to have a second
example both of those
we're going to
one of them is going to be an example of
a problem in
p space the other one is going to be an
example of a problem in np space um and
it's these are going to be important
languages for us so they're not just
going to serve as examples for today but
you know um they're going to be
useful languages for us later on so just
keep that in mind as we're going through
going through it
so
to understand tqbf you have to
understand um
what are called quantified boolean
formulas
or qbfs
so those are boolean formulas just like
the ones we've been seeing we've been
talking about with boolean variables and
the ands ors and and negated variables
um but now you're going to add
quantifiers
exist quantifiers for all quantifiers
if you haven't seen quantifiers you you
need to go back and re you know review
those um
you know i think that we already kind of
introduced talked about them briefly
earlier in the in the term
but um
this is part of the basic math that you
need to know
maybe you'll
not comfortable with them you'll
pick it up somewhat during the course of
the today's and the next few lectures
but anyway
uh
so if you have a boolean formula formula
i'll give you some examples that has
exist and for all quantifiers one of the
requirement for it to be a qbf is that
all of the variables have to be
within the scope of one of the
quantifiers
so you
all of the variables of the formula have
to be quantified
by one of the quantifiers and the we're
going to assume the quantifiers are in
front are sort of leading quantifiers in
front of the rest of the uh
of the of the rest of the expression
so because all of the variables have
been quantified
then a quantified boolean formula is
going to be either true or false
following the meaning of the quantifiers
um and again some of this may become
clear as we do some examples uh
okay
so here are some examples coming
so here is one
here is a qbf
so all of the variables the which are
just x and y they both appear in front
of
uh next to some quantifier so that's
going to be that's a requirement uh if
we have a
qbf
and
so this says for all x there exists a y
this expression
holds
so
we need to kind of unpack that and
understand what it means it says for
every x
for every for every way of assigning
a boolean value to x so
uh x is going to be either true or false
there exists a way of assigning a
boolean value for y to make this true
determined to to make the rest of the
expression hold true
um and
we'll go through that but
let's let's uh contrast
that with the second example where i
invert the order of the quantifiers
because that's going to be important
for the meaning of the formula
so if i say for every x there is a y
which makes this the rest of it true
that says well no matter how i set x
there's going to be a way to set y to
make this true so that says well if i
set x to true
it's got to be some way to set y to make
to make the the the remaining expression
hold
um so if i said x to true what should i
set y to be
um
well
uh
if i said x to be true and maybe i said
y to be true
well then this this clause is uh
satisfied but this clause won't be
satisfied so setting y to be true is not
it won't work but for every x i'm
only need to show there exists some y so
if i pick x to be true i can say y to be
false
um
and now this one is this one holds and
this one holds and the formula holds but
i have to make sure that that's going to
be the case for both settings of x
because
i'm saying for all x so if i said x not
a false because i already showed that it
works for x equal to true if i set x to
false if i set now y to be true
this is going to hold
so this
expression is true
because it is the case that for every
way to set x there is a way to set y
so this part holds
let's look at let's compare that with
this case
is there some way to set y
such that no matter how i said x
this is going to hold
and that's not going to be true no
matter what you pick for y
um there is going to be some way to set
x to make this false
so does it resist a y such that every x
makes us true no
if you try x equal to true it's not
going to work if you try x equal to
false it's not going to work
so this
second fi2
expression quantified qbf is false
okay
we're going to be playing with these a
lot
so it's important to understand
how this
this quantification works
um
so tqbf
is the problem of testing
whether one of these qbfs is true
or
phrased as a language it's the
collection of true qb
true qbfs and that's where we get the um
uh the uh acronym tqbf not acronym the
the the abbreviation tqbf for the true
quantified boolean formulas
so
going back to that example p1 is a true
quantified boolean formula and v2 is not
a true quantified building formula so
that's why
p1 is in the language v2 is not in the
language
now our computational problem is to test
whether
quantified boolean formulas are true or
not
and now we can do in polynomial space
oh there's a check in first
i claim that sat is a special case of
tqbf
why is that
how can we
um
think of sat
as a special case if i give you a sat
formula
how can i see that as also a tqbf
problem if you want to test if that
formula is
true what would you say remove all the
quantifiers
or add some quantifiers and what kind of
quantifiers maybe um
uh how is sat
just testing a formula satisfiable
a special case of this
what i claim is a more general problem
of solving these
tqbf problems
okay
closing down
let's call
yes indeed you know satisfiability
so c is correct
when you're talking about a
satisfiability problem you're saying is
there a satisfying assignment another
way of writing that down is
take the boolean formula represent take
that boolean formula and put
exists in front of all the variables
saying the is there a is there exists
does there exist a way to set x1 and x2
and x3 and x4 to make the formula
true make your formula hold
so um sat is a special case by adding
exist quantifiers
of a tqbf problem
so c is correct
um
okay
so why is this problem in p space
as i claimed and for that we're going to
give a simple recursive algorithm
um
in any
uh a quantified boolean formula now if
you want to test if it's true or not you
know we're going to basically strip off
the leading
quantifiers
so if it's an exist quantifier we'll
remove it and plug in true and false
associated to its
variable
and then solve those problems
recursively
okay so this is just going to be a
recursive procedure for solving
tqbf problems
operating by stripping off the the
quantifiers in front
and uh getting smaller and smaller
formulas but now we're going to be
plugging in uh values true and false um
instead of relying on the quantifier uh
to um uh to to to uh
give us the meaning of the formula
okay
so first of all if there are no
quantifiers then there are no variables
because all variables have to be bound
within quantifiers and in that case the
uh that quantified boolean formula has
to simply be the statement true or the
statement false and so you're going to
output accordingly because that's all it
can be if you have no variables
um
if the formula starts with an exist
quantifier
what you're going to do
so here psi is the remainder of the
formula after you strip off that exist
quantifier
so you're going to evaluate psi now but
take that variable that was bound by the
exist and just plug in true
um
or and false respectively so you're
going to get two two now new problems
um
and
uh
run them
uh and evaluate them using the same
procedure recursively uh but now with x
plugged in for true plugged in for x and
also then with false plug in for x
and
get the answers for those two cases and
if either one of them ended up accepting
then you're going to accept because you
know there exists a value
uh for x which makes the whole thing
true because you you you just
recursively
showed that there was such a value you
know either true or false the thing is
has accepted and if both of them fail
then you're going to reject and the very
same idea if you have a for all
quantifier
you're going to evaluate
the remainder of the formula
again with x equal to true and false so
as two subproblems
but now you're going to require them
both to accept because that's the
meaning of for all that both assignments
to x have to make the formula true so
you're going to
evaluate them recursively and accept
both of them are true as determined by
your recursive your recursion
okay so how much space does this use
um i'm not going to go through this in
great detail but uh
each recursive level uses just a
constant amount of space so every time
you do a recursion you have to remember
that uh
that value uh that assignment to that to
that variable
you want to think of recursion as being
implemented on a stack so you're just
going to pop push on the stack that
value of that variable
which is that true or false so basically
it's one bit of memory uh
that you're going to require every time
you're going down the recursion you just
have to remember what um
you know
which case you're working on whether
x equal to true or x equal to false
uh and
um so each recursive level just involves
constant space
and the depth of the recursion you know
how far how much might you have to
remember well it's going to be at most
one for every quantifier um
because that's you know you're stripping
them off as you're going down the
recursion so that's going to be at most
the length of the formula that says most
of the number of quantifiers you can
have
and so
uh the total amount of space used by
this is going to be um just n order n
okay so this
problem is solved in uh
in n space
and so that's why it's in p space
okay i think that's
all i wanted to say about this
okay if we've got the tape and a turning
machine as memory
in a modern computer what does the
finite control correspond to the finite
control corresponds to just a finite
additional memory um the tape is an
unlimited amount of memory uh or if
we're putting bounds you know the amount
of tape is going to be
say n squared memory where n is the
length of n n is the length of the input
so um
yeah they're both memories but um
the finite control is
it doesn't grow with n so that's going
to be just a you know some constant
amount of memory
what would be the time complexity of
this album time complexity would be bad
it's going to be exponential so you'd
have to just double check that but it's
going to be something like 2
to the
number of variables that you have two to
the number of quantifiers
plus some small overhead for evaluating
the formula multiple time but it's going
to be exponential
um
that's going to answer for you
so someone is asking going back again to
co-np and how do we know there exists a
problem in cohen p that is co and p
complete we didn't define even what that
means
but uh co-np-complete
we're going to start seeing other
examples of completeness for different
complexity classes in particular one of
one thing that's going to happen on
tuesdays we'll see
a problem that's complete for p space
in fact it's going to be tq tqbf
sort of looking ahead is going to
be a piece based complete problem
but
we even have to have the notion of what
we mean by uh complete for these other
classes
and in the case of co np a problem is co
and p complete if it's in in co np and
every other co np problem is polynomial
time reducible to it so just exactly the
same as we have for np just plugging in
co np instead
and
you just have to work through the logic
but it's pretty straightforward
the complement of any np complete
problem is going to be a co-np-complete
problem using that definition um
uh so
just i i don't want to go through
through that those simple steps but
you just can go and verify that offline
that that's
going to be true and i think we're going
to probably talk about that later in the
semester too
um
so another question how does the tqbf
algorithm
ah that is a good question here um
why is the tqbf algorithm that i just
described in p space doesn't the thing
every time i'm doing the recursion
doesn't things branch out so that i end
up using exponential space
critical thing which
i don't i actually don't think i
mentioned which i think is important to
observe is that when you're doing those
two recursive calls when you set x equal
to true and set x equal to false
after you've determined that the the
answer for when you set x equal to true
now you reuse that space
that very same space
to test what happens when you have x
equal to false
so that's that's the power of space
which makes it different from time is
that it can be reused
so after you've got the answer for when
you have x equal to true now you free up
that space that's no longer needed
anymore you just remember the answer and
now you see what happens when you have x
equal to false using that same space so
there's no exponential blow-up that's
that's an important point i'm glad you
gave me the chance to to say it
so somebody's asking about
defining time of an undetermined turing
machine to the maximum
time
of each branch well that's sort of what
we have done maybe i don't understand
your question but you'll have to ask it
after after um afterwards because i want
to i don't want to be delaying any more
than we
that we have
so
we're going to we're going to go back
and
um move on here
okay
second
example
um and this one is a kind of a fun
example but it's also going to be an
important one for us um it's called the
latter problem
now so you may have seen something
called the word ladder
but in general a ladder is a sequence of
strings
which are all of the same length
but where consecutive strings differ in
a single
symbol um
so
so for example if you have a word letter
for english it's going to be a ladder
where all the words are english all of
the um strings are english words so
here's an example
i thought i fixed that okay here is here
is a
a
word ladder for english and maybe you've
seen these suppose i want to try to get
from work to play
but all of the intermediate
uh
strings should be
english words
with four letters
that differ from their previous one in
only a single letter
and i want to somehow change the word
work
to the word play so i don't know if
you know so for example i can change
work to pork
so here's just one letter difference
um which looks like it's an improvement
because now i have the i'm agree an
agreement on the play
um but sometimes you know you might
change it you might have a good change
and then you have to undo it later which
i think actually happens here um
so pork then this port but then we gave
up that progress we made port
to sort
to suit
to slot you understand again you
understand what i'm doing here each case
i'm just changing a single letter
but all of these words all of these have
to be legitimate english words of length
four
plot
ploy
and then play
okay
so that's what a word lighter in english
would be of course you can do it in
different languages and i'm going to
talk about it abstractly where
instead of having any natural human
language as being the uh test for a word
b for being a string being legitimate
i'm going to define a
um
any old language
uh let's let's say it's a is going to be
some language some set of strings and
the and the
those are going to be the legal strings
that can be in the ladder
so a ladder in a is a lot of strings
that are all members of a
um
and now the
the
latter dfa problem is
a is going to be the language of some
dfa
so i'm giving you b
um
and so i want and then a start string
and an n string so this is like work and
play u and v are like work and play so
where b is a dfa
and its language has a ladder that goes
from u to v
here are the intermediate strings
okay
and
all right um
so
um
i'm going to show you that this latter
dfa problem is in np space
okay and it's not this is not super hard
because basically
uh well
let's just actually
look at the slide here
the way it's going to work is it's not
deterministically going to guess that
sequence from u to v
so if i if i'm trying to get from work
to play imagine those i'm going to be
using this as um
you know
in place of the
uh the
of the language of my fine art automaton
just because this is easier to talk
about but imagine these are being
strings that are that are accepted by
that that dfa
um so now i'm trying to get from my
string u to the string v and i want to
test can i get there
by some
uh changing one letter at a time but
staying as strings that are accepted by
the dfa
um
i'm just going to guess that sequence
non-deterministically
but i have to make sure careful of two
things um
i don't want to guess the sequence solid
in advance because that sequence might
be exponentially long
you have to calculate how long it could
possibly be but you might
might you know you might change to one
symbol then change it to a different
symbol then change it back to that
original symbol or
so
the the only bound that you can write
down is the number of possible strings
that you can have of that length
um so it might be exponential uh you
don't want to write down that whole
thing because that's going to be
exceeding your space bound
but what you don't need to you're just
going to guess them one at a time
forgetting about the previous ones just
keep guessing the next uh one in the
sequence and only remembering that one
and seeing if uh
you're ever get to the the string your
you your target string
but then when you do that you have to
make sure that you don't end up going
forever
um because that's not allowed
in your uh in your um
in your np space algorithm
uh
so
you're going to have to keep a counter
to make sure that if you go beyond that
bound which is going to be the maximum
number of strings you could possibly
have then you're going to just shot that
branch of the non-determinism off
you're going to just reject on that
branch
okay so here is i'm going to write to
say this here
here is my non-deterministic uh
you know polynomial space procedure
um i'm given my language my dfab and my
start and end strings
i let y equal the start string
write down the length of my strings that
i'm going to have to keep
in mind all the way through
and then i'm going to just repeat the
following t times where t is the maximum
length as can be which is the the size
of the alphabet of these of these things
to the nth power where m is the length
of those strings
uh and i'm just going to not
deterministically change one symbol
at a time
making sure that i'm staying in the
language
so rejecting immediately if that change
introduced a
string outside the language
and accepting if that string that i get
by changing that single symbol
is now my target
um
and if i've gone through my bound and i
haven't managed to reach
that target then i'm just going to
reject
and we just have to observe that this
algorithm
doesn't use too much space
so if you imagine what we need here
here's my input unv
which is of length n
and the total amount of space i just
have to remember the current y
um
and um
and also my counter t my counter up to t
so um each of those can be written down
with it with uh essentially in space so
the total amount is going to be order n
space
um
so that shows that uh this latter dfa
problem is actually in non-deterministic
space n
not deterministic linear space
um
and what we're going to show next
is that this language is actually
solvable in deterministic space and this
is kind of perhaps a bit of a surprise
okay um
so what's the size of the input the size
of the input is
uh going to be what it takes to write
down the uh the dfa and the uh the two
strings u and v um
so uh
um here
uh
yeah i mean i i should have also
included as part of the input
the the description of b itself
but um
uh so
but that's going to even work in my
favor because um
so this this is slightly incorrect
because b itself has to appear as part
of the input so apologies for that but
still the amount of uh space used is
going to be order n
um because these are going to be
actually less than n
um
so let me
jump be so we don't run out of time for
the lecture we can save additional
questions for
afterward i'll stick around for a few
minutes i just really have one more
slide here um and that is proving this
theorem that ladder can be done in
deterministically in polynomial space
and that's going to be
important as a kind of a
preview of what we're going to be doing
on tuesday
and you know
if this goes a little fast i'll go over
it again on tuesday so let's just see
how it goes so i'm going to show the
same ladder dfa problem
is solvable deterministically
in
polynomial space and but this time it's
going to be in squared space instead of
non-deterministically in end space so
there's going to be some cost but it's
only going to be a squaring
so remember what the problem is
you know i'm giving you that dfa
and giving you two strings in the
language of that dfa and i want to know
can i get
from one
the first string to the second string by
changing one symbol at a time but always
making sure that the strings are
along the way are accepted by that dfa
okay
so i'm going to introduce notation
saying
can i get from string u to v by a ladder
but now i'm limiting how many steps i
can take so i'm writing u to v but doing
it only within b
b intermediate strings b steps
so is there a ladder from u to v of
length at most b
that's what it means to write this
notation down
so i'm going to
uh give you a recursive procedure to
solve
the bounded ladder problem where it's
just like the before but now i'm going
to
say not only does there a ladder from u
to v but there's a ladder of length at
most b
okay so that's going to allow me to
solve the latter problem recursively by
shrinking the size of b
um
uh
okay
so um
let's how is this going to work
uh
um
well here's going to be the idea
so here is my u and my v
um
and the procedure is going to work by
instead of
non-deterministically guessing
the steps that take me from work to play
because i don't have non-determinism
anymore i have to operate
deterministically
what i'm going to do is
work instead of
um
i'm going to instead of going from
looking at the very first
thing that follows from from you i'm
going to jump right to the middle
and try every possible middle string
oh i have no clue even what that middle
string should look like so i'm going to
try all possibilities in the sequence
but then i'm going to use once i have
one of those possibilities i'm going to
recursively try to solve the problem by
splitting that now but i'm now going to
divide that b value in half
okay so here is the maximum value we can
have this is the t from the previous
slide which is the maximum length um
and i uh
here i'm going to try every possible
intermediate let's start off with a
all a's
um
and now i cut the problem in half can i
get from work to all a's and all a's to
play well very first thing i should
check is making sure that all a's
in fact is a string uh in the language
and if we're thinking of the languages
sort of you know matching it's like
english all a's is not
a legitimate word so you try the next
one
aab and this is how it's going to work
but now you're going to be instead of
using english you're going to feed it
into the finite automaton just one after
the next trying every possibility until
you know like a clock
like a like an odometer
trying them all
until eventually you find a string
that's in the language
sort of i'm representing that by an
english word able maybe that's the first
word that you would have found and then
once you find that you're gonna
can i get from work to able and able to
play recursively reusing the space again
but now where the bound is cut in half
okay so that's that's the whole album
so
um
just going through it quickly and we'll
do this again um
uh
here is my
dfa going from u to v within b steps
first of all
oh this is bad uh t should not be one b
this should be b if b is one um
can i quickly fix that
uh so these t's should be b's my
apologies
um
so if t is one if b is one
then they have to d then i'm only
allowed a a ladder of length one now i
just check at the media directly do you
and v different in just
in one place
if yes then accept else i reject
uh if it's greater than one now i'm
going to do this procedure that i
described i'm going to try for each
possible w
uh
in the middle
um
i'm gonna
try that w test whether i can get from u
to w in half the number of steps and
from w to v in half the number of steps
and except if they both accept um
and if trying all possible w's
none of them work then i know that
there's no way to get from u to v and b
steps and so then i reject
okay and then to do
the original problem which was not the
bounded ladder problem i just do the
bounded line i do the bounded ladder
problem
where i put in t which is the maximum
possible length that it could be to get
from work to play out to get from u to v
okay so the space analysis
um
well i'm kind of out of time here so
we're going to go through this again
next time
we have a very quick
so let me skip that uh analysis i'll
review this next time i have a very
quick check-in i just want to get to you
get get here
um
find an english word
letter that connects the word must to
the word vote
you can think about that i mean i it's
not that hard to come up with such a
word ladder uh so i encourage you
to think about that also to think about
voting which is also important
that's coming up
um
okay another five seconds here
okay i'm gonna end this so make sure you
get your credit for the check-in
okay so uh we're at the end of the hour
um
into the end of the night
end of the 80 minutes anyway uh so this
is what we did today
um
and
looks like i ran over by a minute so my
apologies
and but i'll stick around here um if any
of you have any further questions so but
otherwise
uh lecture is over
uh see you guys
do we know anything about ladder for
other kinds of languages
i i don't know
um uh interesting question whether you
can say uh some nice things about the
latter
um
the latter um problem in other in other
cases i don't know
okay why is t here this value of t
sigma to the m the maximum length
of a um of a word letter so what did
what first of all we have to m maybe i
should have written this down m is the
the the length
of the words
uh sigma is the alphabet
um
so the number of possible different
words is sigma to the m
these are all possible words that there
could possibly be
so uh
there's no
reason in a word like
or ever to repeat the word because you
can just find a shorter word ladder that
still does the job of connecting to
connecting
a start in the end
so you can just cut out that middle
part um the repeated part
so
in that case
the longest possible
word letter is going to be the total
number of possible words that you can
have which is going to be sigma the size
of sigma to the m
explain again why cohen p is a subset of
p space
um
well
maybe i'll say it this way
take the
why is
why is every co np language also in pd
space
well take the complement of your co-mp
language that's an np language
an np language is in p space because we
proved that that's what we proved um
uh
but if a language is in p space its
complement is also in p space because
for a deterministic procedure you can
just flip the answer of the machine
um so now you get
you know if so if b language b is in
cohen p its complement b b complement is
an np which is in p space but now so b
complement is in p space so now
p space you can invert the answer and
now b is also in p space i hope that
helps um
somebody's giving me the answer to get
from uh
uh must to vote but you know i i i've
seen an answer and that's you know there
are online tools
that will answer word letters um
so you just
plug in the two you know
where the start and the finish and it'll
give you the word ladder and then the
one that this person is
sent me is the one you get from that
that tool so i suspect it didn't find it
himself i i actually uh before lecture i
actually saw that on my own besides the
one that i know the one that the one
that the tool will give you so that tool
gives one in uh i think five steps and i
found one on my own of six steps it's
not that hard but yeah must
most
lost lose
rose wrote and vote
i think maybe that's seven steps
um
anyway you see you can solve the for
short words you can solve these
generally pretty quickly on your own
um
what else what else can i do for you
do we need to worry about coming back to
a previously visited word visited word
on the construction on this page
no we don't have to worry about coming
back to a previously visited word all
you need to worry about is making sure
that you bound how long you're going to
go for
and that's where the previously visited
issue
comes in
you know if the
um
[Music]
if the word letter that you found
repeats some word
well then there would would have been a
shorter word ladder that would have also
worked but uh
you know it still shows that it's
possible to get from the
uh
the start word to the finish word um
if you if you're if you have a repeated
one in between so that that doesn't
matter
we don't have to worry about that
if you did then it would be a problem
so i think i will it's four or five i
think i want to head out uh
see you all guys and i'm going to join
my tas in the meeting shortly so bye-bye
thank you for being here
you